bien dans mon esprit je vous trouve
surclasse turtle quoi faire parler notre
ce qu'il savait qu'on en a ok c'est
parti c'est un jeu extrêmement simple au
grand nez sur des camions on peut
ralentir le temps voilà pour ajuster sa
chute et le but c'est de ne jamais
toucher le sol et d'internât ligne
d'arrivée est là après horrible c'est le
mais là on n'est pas trop dégueu quoi ça
se passe plutôt bien pas grand chose à
faire on est bien le bel complète et
bien à mon avis ça vite fait partir aux
couilles
en fait les camions des accidents a
plutôt des les moutons attend au laos
voilà la c6 est encore le fait accompli
c'est génial comme passé mais je trouve
dommage ralentit pas le temps on n'a pas
le temps de ralentir le temps où
voici tes limites on a fait une sorte de
petit slide des familles ok c'est bon
c'était limite
mais c'est les gars c'est trop simple
regardez on attend la voilà enfin je
vais le mal à encaisser sac scoop it
déjà énormément mais c'est pas grave on
a le courage on t'a si ces conducteurs
étaient pas bourré aussi ou way au nom
j'ai fait un truc trop cool ouah
olalalala j'ai arraché mardi j'aurais
tellement pas du coi ok en fait faut
prendre un saut énorme à l'arrivée du
bordel genre le bronze top des familles
ça me fait plaisir à bientôt après il
faut aller sur un quai à gauche en fait
je pense regarder devant l'aca par un
steak
on y va on y va on y va on se ralentit
juste pour intérêts sur le parquet se
plaît je tape à l'oeil
[Musique]
entre les deux on était en belgique l'on
demandait à vaudreuil de cabillaud
on est bien là au web pourquoi
pourquoi alors la mecque et jean-michel
cascades auquel on est bien au non mais
pourquoi pourquoi le budget reste
bloquée au scandale en fait à chaque
fois que je refais ça se passe papa et
sacchi compliqué du coup je dois de
nouveau anticipé par exemple ce camion
au haut niveau mais enfin level 9 bat on
va et sur lequel beaucoup de vent et on
va réussir
d'accord j'ai compris la blague du
contresens ok là ça passe bien ce qui se
passe là
non ah je sais affecté les chiottes et
je trouvais technique il faut se mettre
sur un quai derrière comme celui là plus
de chances de passer auquel on est bien
on n'est pas du tout bien on se perd sur
le côté ça passe ça passe ça pas s'il
vous plaît auquel on en route mais qu'on
est en route pour la victoire
non qu il faut sur les camions qui est
par terre en fait j'aime pas trop les
jours il ya une part de chance qu elle a
de la chance presse et n'excuse de
communauto temps on est bien là à ce
temps on la passe est sauté vraiment la
bulle 2014 alors la mecque je pense à
partir en couille mais le monumental
coadry juste des pancartes
qu'est-ce que cela est dur bon après
j'ai fait parti d'ali d'un dj daddy le
hall à podcaster sépare voit rattrapé
mairie on va moins ça fait derrière spam
aller voilà on attend je dois la
technique tu te fais sur le capot et tu
passes tous les trucs sans les mains
bâtard et voilà comment casser un jeu
vidéo en une seconde tout est passé de m
18 donc le sol se met à bouger là bas
mais ça c'est pas un problème pour nous
ok ou là il va tomber sur la ola là là
je n'ai qu'une philosophie être le poing
levé voilà c'est passé par le level 23
et j'en passe du lobel 17 avant de
soigner des problèmes aux la glace qui
bouge
[Musique]
non mais qu alors la mecque on est en
train de passer le saut au aux
il en reste
il ya deux succès beaucoup trop violent
où il arrivait encore la somme est
arrêté et cette troisième rencontre sans
tomber les gars puissent arrêter
ok technique capot mais t'es un mec
c'est pas moi perdre je t'en supplie je
vous en supplie alors je suis passé ces
boues fantastique alors là ça part sur
des anneaux parfait fait passer entre
eux un mec là parfait je tomberai moment
le seul truc avec quoi on va sauter du
coup d'ici
oh là là mais cette réception aller
toujours plus d'anneaux mexique
excellent au nom hockey sont ralentis
parce qu'on est des gens michel pall tu
en voilà le mec il a ce qu'il c'est
abusé
oh là là là là mais les fraude à
steve lebel 32 ans non mais là ça
commence à être beaucoup trop dur avec
ses quoi s'attelle à sa place au t2
ligne en ligne c'est ça olalala la
réception cutanées oh là là ce qu'on
fait c'est qu'on va même pas les deux
ralentis parce que on est dans le futur
envoyé on peut passer tous les camions
vraiment d'une manière aisée des troncs
pile ou face ça ça va de plus en
plus vite bec
[Musique]
au départ c'est un arrêté de vouloir me
faire des trucs comme van damme j'en ai
marre le mail 33 qui existent pas assez
d'être est partout cd laser
non non mais là il faut juste à la
chance là on va juste prier
voilà allez tous à nos prières
auquel esquive mec tu essaies rio attend
la venue pas classé pas à la chance
non tout ce qu'ils voient ça la chance
je retiens vraiment ce que je veux dire
oh oh oh oh là s'annonce déjà plus de
style que le truc avant je trouve ça
d'abord aux mets tellement in extremis
mais non il reste un dernier au jeu
jouer ce jeu est vraiment génial
ça pas sûr un délire de marteau
destructeur on en parle c'est bon je
suis réfugié allait vraiment aucun
camion qui est passé avec tussle perdu
sur vous sur mon sol j'ai perdu on va
finir sur ce caméra c'est celui-là qu'on
aime et aucun autre merde merde merde
ok
sur eux ok ça passe sa part sur une
favela do tout le monde mais avec 43
annonce être la même chose en pire au
nom regarder ce qu a été ok au la mer le
bordel au carpates fait juste roches y
regarder on est bien là alors tu les
deux camions qui se barre ils me voient
dans son rétro il se barre sans moi mais
non mais non mais non c'est pourquoi les
camions s'écarte quoi j'arrive non
j'suis baiser non lui s'en sort on est
mort de même 44 ans non mais j'en ai
marre de ces domaines-là arrêter
vraiment revenir le m8 plus je sens bien
lui puis je sens bien que c'est un
survivant dans la vie dit mais non mais
non je passe et ouais mais le 46 c'est
quoi ce délire la ouate ok d'accord ces
plateformes usant du sol et ce qu'on
fait du premier coup oh mais que ces
violents à quel rythme se lève non olala
suis camion nouvelle 47 un plaisir
beaucoup en kanaky pas cela et je le
chope en plein vol attendu par willy
buysse à boxer je veux tellement qu'ils
s'en bat les couilles
bravo la réussite butin ce jeu est fait
quoi merci d'avoir joué vous avez fait
la halle fois en 25 minutes neuf
secondes ans déjà mais ce que je veux
dire ah c'était génial
oui mais les gens certains de ces
données citées pas aller mais si le
style vous a plu mais aujourd'hui on est
est ce qu'il est non mais ah ben j'ai
adoré ce jeu voilà j'ai rien d'autre à
ajouter
le principe est tout court mais c'est
juste génial on a vraiment envie de
réussir chaque niveau alors j'attends la
prochaine vidéo portez vous bien chez
toi en bis
[Musique]